(bright music)
Here's a little weekday motivation
from someone who inspires us.
Hi Drew, this is Rachel Montez Minor.
I'm an actress, dancer, and singer.
And now I'm the author of the children's book,
"The Sun, The Moon, and The Stars."
And I can't wait to share it with all of you.
I had a deep meditation practice
and when I became pregnant with my daughter,
I had a dream and I saw the cover of this book
with the title in the middle
and children sitting around it in a circle.
And then all of the words of the book
just were downloaded to me.
It's unconventional.
And 12 books came that way during my pregnancy.
I do believe because I spend so much time in nature
and meditate a lot that, you know,
that's how the book kind of chose me.
I think if we create space in our life
through taking a deep breath, getting out in nature,
taking a walk, deciding to look up at the sun and the trees
and the clouds,
and take a break from looking down at your phone,
allowing some time that is uncontrolled,
even if it's just a daydream,
that's when we can get our inspiration.
It can let magic in our lives.
Thank you for sharing that with us.
(bright music)